and even when Adam's being honest right
he's saying
oh you know like I kind of felt a type
of way about it and now my question to
you Adam is what is more misogynistic
for all of the the simp man and I'm
sorry because that is simply letting
your girl
screw another guy when you are a tall
good looking multi-millionaire okay and
you accept her having sex with another
man for money who is the real misogynist
who who hates women what's more
misogynistic telling them things that
are true or pimping out women for money
he uses women's Beauty he monetizes
women's Beauty and I know a guy that age
knows that there are negative
consequences for women in the long run
that do that type of stuff much more
than men if we live in reality instead
of peddling these lies what is more
honest to women